billions of years ago another planet
smashed into earth
an event of this epicness could have
created our moon
it also could have brought alien life to
our planet
what evidence of this planet still
exists on earth today
could there be life deep inside the
earth's surface
and could that life be an advanced
civilization of humanoid aliens
this is what if and here's what would
happen if aliens are living inside the
earth
four and a half billion years ago thea a
proto-planet the size of mars struck our
young earth
this collision scattered pieces of both
planets into space
and many scientists argue that these
pieces eventually coalesced into our
moon
but what happened to the rest of thea is
still a mystery
the existence of blobs of material
inside earth's mantle known as low shear
velocity provinces
could be evidence that parts of thea
fused with earth
these chunks are up to 1 000 kilometers
in height and several times that in
width
they sit below africa and the pacific
ocean straddling earth's core like a
pair of headphones
but other theories some dating back
centuries suggest a completely different
explanation of what exists under the
surface
a lush tropical paradise for aliens
the earth consists of four layers the
crust the mantle and the outer and inner
core
but there hasn't been any successful
exploration below the crust so there's
much we don't know about the realities
below the surface
this has led to spectacular speculation
like the hollow earth theory
according to this theory our planet
could be a series of nested spheres
centered around a central core
in between these shells atmospheres
could exist that are capable of
supporting life
in the 17th century edmund halley the
scientist who discovered halley's comet
backed this theory
many others have added to it suggesting
a small sun could be hanging in the
center of the earth and plants animals
and humans could be living there
and not just humans but a race of
superhumans
immortals who possess sophisticated
technology to build hundreds of
subterranean cities
but if there were aliens inside the
earth
what would the conditions for life be
could the inside of our planet be a
luscious paradise
or a hot hellish dump
if you were to visit one of the low
sheer velocity provinces you'd have to
go 2 900 kilometers below the surface
here you'd be surrounded by magma or
liquid rock with temperatures as high as
3 700 degrees celsius
and the weight of the crust and mantle
above you would increase the pressure to
over 237
000 times the atmospheric pressure you
know on the surface of the earth
whatever life you find here would need
to exist in these extreme conditions
and these life forms would need to
evolve to extract oxygen directly from
the magma
or live without it
they'd need to survive without any
sunlight
radiation would be the primary energy
source
and lucky for them the radioactive decay
of uranium thorium and potassium in the
earth's crust and mantle already account
for the primary source of heat in the
earth's interior
there could be all kinds of undiscovered
creatures down there but until you could
withstand the pressure and heat to find
out
we'll never know
and as for the hollow earth well
it's nice to imagine a paradise world
underneath our feet instead of layers
upon layers of hot molten rock
and who knows
maybe there is alien life down there
just like all those underwater aliens
hiding in the world's deepest lake
oh wait
that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]
you